dominic besner bonsoir alors c'est calme
c'est les starlettes et on a le meilleur
caster de france à caster c'est un mot
un peu ou rien que caster ça fait un peu
des buteurs castor et pollux énorme
envie en france on dit baladeur on peut
bien dire caster sonné casting directeur
d'enfants dit en fait content dit
catherine handicap stricte et un casting
ce fut un quatre mains tenant je suis un
agent plus avant parlons d'abord du
casting tu as découvert que j'ai
découvert j'ai découvert j'ai aidé une
génération de jeunes l'actrice est de
jeunes acteurs
en tout les a trouvés ou con que mon
bonheur alors venir c'est un peu
particulier bonheur moi je travaille sur
le film n a écrit à france soir et c'est
pas lui c'est plutôt qu'à l'aquila il a
les qualités pour rien su non j'étais
pourriez il m'a montré les on a fait les
gestes et j'ai vu ensuite les essais
j'ai vu qu'elle était fort mais la
menace est elle même de son propre chef
quelle rigueur chris dale oen facilement
c'est mon moment
des shows pour a lâché ma chouchoute et
en plus c'est mon ma vraie réalisation
ben c'est à dire que je vais rencontrer
pour 37 degrés le matin je ferai une
enquête
je faisais tous les cons d'art
dramatique comme d'habitude ce qu'il
faut dire qu'avant d'arrêter des gens
dans la rue sur les photos demain doit
d'abord où ils peuvent à toi ou
géomètres et quand on n'a pas trouvé ce
moment on trouve que les six dans les
courses c'est rarement des magnifiques
parce que les jolies filles agents pas
me donne à les embêter à apprendre de la
tragédie ou des doutes ou du feydeau
pour s'extérioriser
elles sont belles elles vont à la
rencontre des mecs dans la rue je leur
propose de faire des photos et donc
elles n'ont pas de problème c'est dans
la rue
landudal c'est sur une photo d'un du
nord lui qui a fait les photos roddick a
disparu et j'ai vu une fille qui faisait
une grimace tri match incroyable city
aux spurs à la voix rauque et chaude
mènerait la langue alors binoche elle
c'était dans la rue au moment où elle
allait au conservatoire pas tout pour
aller voir les auditions de fin d'année
et ensuite je les fais mien je me mêle
la plus belle chose sur juliette
excellent premier rendez-vous c'était
pratique de pierre granier 2
et elle avait 16 ans et on cherchait une
fille de trajan et je lui dis tu dis que
tu as 13 ans élu je pourrai jamais et
quand est immédiatement des sondages
pierre runique et là je vous avais elle
a dit j'ai 13 ans il veut tellement où
elle joue et on n'avait pas de la
comédie voit la belle elle a rougi et il
a cru qu'elle était timide en fait parce
qu'elle mentait qu'elle devenait rouge
café speedway kaprisky je les rencontre
et les plus futés des photos elle était
dans une agence de mannequins chez
régine et je lui ai fait faire un film
tout appelé les hommes préfèrent les
grosses
elle était la beauté du fil et le film
elle s'appelait pas kaprisky encore
tafer valérie charrette ouais donc c'est
un peu toi quoi
oui c'est un peu moins mais c'est moi
qui ai trouvé son premier rôle en
revendiquait cette merde chez toi
detmers elle était dans un cours oui je
le suis présenté godard parce que adjani
avait quitté s'étaient pas entendus avec
godard et on a appelé
merde et je les rencontrer au cours
florent où elle était et elle est à ce
moment là elle avait pas de fric elle
vivait dans une chambre de bonne et elle
le fait de garder la cg la nounou je
vais arrêter fillon perd sitter
valandrey sétois val-andré alors elle
elle est venue sur les hors la loi elle
avait 15 ans et senna ont refusé
qu'elles ont passées mais ce qu'il y
avait des scènes érotiques en famille à
0,10 alors moi c'est un gars et ses
parents étaient un peu ses parents qui
sont adorables sont déjà fait sa voix là
et ils n'ont pas voulu que leur trig est
du reste quand le grand père a vu le
film ils ont ils voulaient couper la
scène de l'alhambra tus et leurs biens
tu dois recevoir pas mal de lettres j'en
sois beaucoup il ya des gens qui défie
qui m'a tellement dans la rue surtout
les sticks l'élan à supporter les
garçons se trouvait que chris campion
d'enterrer ses toiles en zac
à cech hilario cet outil cariou qui j'ai
bouffé des christophe lambert et il
était au conservatoire mais j'ai un
moment donné j'ai fait toutes les
erreurs s'écrit alors un mec que tu as
vu venir les gens codina bon j'avoue
j'ai été j'ai vraiment manqué de flair
mais il voulait à tout prix faire diva
il est comme il a il avait une
personnalité comme ça très qui en
voulait il a siégé le bureau il me
gonfle et complètement en même temps il
avait envie il était persuadé qu'il
était drôle et en fin de compte ils me
l'ont fait tellement j'ai peut-être que
les champs et il y en a un par contre
c'est une star maintenant et que j'ai
vraiment découvert pour débat s'était
plaint en find a way il est numéro 1 au
top 500 était lui alors c'est là aussi
la de la vie où le destin les gens c'est
que quand je vais rencontrer il était
barman dans un bar qui s'appelait le
brancher deux fois et donc j'ai fait
venir elle juge de chercher un accord
maintenant pour de bas étage qui doit ce
qui est passionné d'opéra il m'a dit je
reprends l'opéra au conservatoire de
levallois et c'est parce qu'il était
tellement
naturel que la productrice a vraiment a
eu peur de lui parce que dans ce film
n'est il vient posément à la rn20 mais
il aurait été génial dans et puis comme
autre cia et les lentilles à nice elle
comprenait pas encore très bien les
belles d'avancé car joue avec de longs
gants
comment ils s'appellent eux valentina
vargas
cependant avec samuel fuller avec kaka
dynamiquement clouté rémunéré après je
dis rien alors moi non donc ça je reste
moi en tant que la tension était pendant
deux ans dans dix ans et depuis deux ans
je suis entré chez artmédia qu'il a une
grande agence maintenant tu continues à
toucher de l'argent que ses filles
deviennent très célèbre g 10 % de leur
salaire
ça me rassure parce que je me demandais
comment tu amènes mais quand je fais des
du casting aidés payés par le producteur
c'est tout lui s'était payé une fois
pour toutes je veux dire
non là maintenant je suis devenu un peu
macro avant joue les way avant fans
compte j'étais c'était juive et d'amour
et d'eau fraîche et maintenant j'ai
décidé de prendre 10% sur l'or mais toi
tu as tu as envie de jouer dans des
films que j'ai joué dans des films pas
jouer un jour j'ai besoin d'en manger
jouer avec pauline lafont dans possible
de granby que les temps devant nous une
dizaine de films moi mais moi ça m'amuse
comme ça mais peuple avec pialat c'est
extraordinaire parce que tu as envie des
fois quand tu lis à un scénario envie
d'aller toucher à moi tu cherches une
jeune actrice moins jeunes acteurs de
dire j'aime ce rôle il serait formidable
jamais je pense à moi on reste à nos
amours puis à là il m'a appelé j'ai pu
traiter de plaisanterie au début et en
fin de compte il m'a fait faire des
essais et moi je voulais pas faire des
cdd vous prenez vous prenez la
principale le questeur qui veut pas
faire des langages voulait pas faire
d'excès je vais vous me connaissez
suffisamment weight watchers fait des dt
je me souviens que les premiers de cette
éthique j'ai fait il m'a dit voilà je
tendais la vitesse est comme cela qu
avec maurice
j'avais vu ses précédents il fallait lui
avoir des rapports un peu tendu j'ai
pris ça en bonheur que j'ai foutu une
claque dans la nuit les médias arrêtent
du feu rouge est bon ensuite on a voulu
refaire cette scène pendant tout le film
il ya la violence qui a eu à 7 pendant
les deux heures l'a jamais retrouvé et
tous les rings et à la même heure à la
main molle et en fin de compte c'était
peut-être parce que c'était une
provocation sa doctrine en formation en
tant qu'acteur dans mon propre aux
fesses vous savez que lorsqu'on est
agent on n'a pas le droit de détracteurs
c'est à dire on n'a pas le droit de il
ya un syndicat on n'a pas le droit de
jouer la comédie et d'autres cupide
acteurs d'une loi et là je crois que
j'ai demandé une dérogation parce qu'on
m'a demandé pour jouer luis salom tout
soit plaisir de faire ça alors ça serait
très bien oui en plus il avait les yeux
bleus comme toi oui c'est un personnage
que j'adore parce qu'en même temps c'est
on dit que c'est un faible et lâche on
veut et en maintenant ce que c'est un
poète et jamais il n'a pas été compris
celles tettey qui s'est laissé dominer
par une femme relève de loïs est vrai
c'est que c'était pas l'aîné et avait un
frère aîné qui devait trois écrivains
accident enfin tu
tu le sais sûrement il s'est retrouvé
roi il s'y attendait pas du tout il n'y
est pas trop mal sorti finale en même
temps oui bon et en plus il a été
courageux et moi pourquoi tu m'a jamais
demandé de jouer en afrique aussi j'ai
déjà pour jeter déjà de entendu fait des
sous-entendus mais c'est pas secrètes
c'est aimerait jouer en arrivant
toilettes et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous y
mettez un peu de bleu